a disease I'm the founding director of
children's global network in Pakistan
and working on compulsory education for
all children equity-based I'm at the
World Economic Forum in India and i'll
be talking on the gender parity and
specially focusing on girls education in
Pakistan because that's it's a right
it's not a privilege so we get the
starting point of the discussion i find
the World Economic Forum for India to be
a very important forum and specially for
the region and Pakistan for interaction
with the word are possible very strong
ally and both both the countries can be
working together on a people-to-people
basis and especially in the education
sector we have a lot of common
challenges and common advantages that we
can both the countries can strengthen
and work towards goals of achieving a
hundred percent literacy in both
countries and that is what Pakistan is
aspiring to do so now and we look
forward to more collaboration and the
forum is an exceptionally good
interaction networking point2 to inform
the public and to be informed of what is
going on in Pakistan